Democrat conspiracy theorists come up
empty on Russia Democrat superstore in
socialists empty head Alexandria Ocasio
Cortez embarrasses herself on television
again I blame Allie Stuckey I always
blame Allie Stuckey and everything is
looking great for Republicans heading
into the midterms so the left is
resorting to rehashing long-dead history
and renaming entire cities because
leftism is nothing but a tale told by an
idiot full of sound and fury signifying
nothing we'll talk about that we will
talk about the sound and fury of leftism
with comedian Jamie kill Steen when he
comes on the show to discuss how he
broke his addiction to sjw online
slacktivism jamie is a true breath of
fresh air in Hollywood even for a lefty
finally we will discuss why entitlements
are impossible to repeal on this day in
history
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
a lot to get to let's jump right into it
in one second after I make a little
money honey and talk to you about
software advice this is really important
I wish I had this when I was starting my
political company because it would have
saved me a lot of time and money when
you're dealing with a real
head-scratcher or having your go-to
person to call is a no-brainer and that
is why you need software advice picking
the right software for your business is
tough you don't know where you know you
don't know what the options are you
don't know what the best choices are for
your business software advice has done
all of the research for you that their
team of advisors can point you in the
right direction you can start working
more effectively right away and here's
the catch folks everything's got a catch
it's completely free
that's the catch there's no catch it is
an unbelievable service I really really
wish I had this you would be foolish not
to try it out go to software advice.com
slash Knolls KO wles answer a few short
questions about your business you'll be
connected with an advisor to discuss the
best software options for your needs
talking to an advisor takes just 10
minutes or less and it will save you I'd
say I remember starting a business I
remember 'king in businesses in the low
stage it can take weeks to figure out
the right software you can waste a lot
of time and money don't do it whether
you're a medical professional
construction manager or HR pro you name
it anything else
software advice will save you time and
help you make a more informed decision
in the software struggle today go to
software advice comm slash Knolls ken o
wles like Beyonce to get started that's
software advice.com slash Knowles ano
wles like Beyonce to connect with the
software advisor with an advisor for
free software advice com / / what /
Knowles okay let's jump right into it so
the media they're so sad because they
they were gonna get Trump they were
gonna get him this was gonna be the big
midterm splash it was gonna create the
blue wave Democrats we're gonna sail in
over all of the crimes the high crimes
and misdemeanors that President Trump
committed and what do we have mayor
Giuliani take it away this is very
damning for Trump there's criminal
liability here for the president on the
horizon with these claims well Rudy
Giuliani president Trump's attorney
former New York City Mayor I've been
sitting here looking in the federal code
trying to find collusion as a crime
it's not collusion is not a crime
collusion is not a crime we had
Professor Alan Dershowitz come on the
show the other day to talk about this
it's not a crime they've been trying to
find a crime they said there is
something with Russia there's something
nefarious and they've been using this
vague word collusion president Trump
colluded but that doesn't really mean
anything
what is collusion what is clear is the
crime of collusion to find nowhere
because it's not a crime it's a vague
scare word to try to make you think that
President Trump is like Boris from Rocky
and Bullwinkle
you know boris and Natasha and so
they've been waiting they said where
they were gonna mana for it's gonna get
something isn't he all right
I'm sorry Muller is gonna get something
for instance with the former a campaign
chairman Paul Manafort or with
Papadopoulos or with this guy or with
that guy we're gonna get him we're gonna
get him and they've come up short
they've come up with nothing right now
man afford is heading to trial and we
know what the trial is going to be about
you know this is about Paul Manafort had
set up shell companies we know that he
accepted a lot of Ukrainian money we
know that he laundered a little bit of
money kept it in offshore bank accounts
what has not been mentioned what all
analysts are saying likely will not be
mentioned in that man afford trial is
the 2016 election President Trump were
really Russia at all that just isn't
there so the big get the big scalp that
special counsel Robert Mulder has so far
doesn't seem to have anything to do with
what Muller was appointed to investigate
they got nothing they've got nothing and
so they keep harping on that vague were
this a collusion there's collusion
what's Kalu what's the crime of
collusion Alan Dershowitz came on the
show he said President Trump could have
called up Vladimir Putin said of a
Vladdy
I got some favors for you if you can
release those emails if you've got them
even that would not be a crime even that
is not against the law so they've really
come up empty CNN knows this Siena knows
this they ran a headline this morning I
took a screenshot of it I'll love it
this is a big headline on Apple News and
I take a CNN screenshot almost every day
because they get more and more
ridiculous the headline was Trump opens
window into his rage with Muller attack
that was see that's the news headline
that was on Apple news like the main
thing when I woke up this morning and I
think they might be projecting a little
bit I
CNN is opening a window into its own
rage because they can't get anything on
Trump they aren't able to impeach him he
hasn't committed a crime so they say
whenever you read that Trump Trump opens
the window into his rage is that is that
like poetry or is that is that you know
at the beginning to a novel or is that
the news it's certainly not the news
this brings us to the next peg they were
really hoping okay we can't get anything
with President Trump we don't have any
crimes and he committed with Russia so
we're gonna run our superstar energetic
candidate the far left running on the
Democrat wing of the Democrat Party
she's gonna sail us to victory except
she doesn't know anything here is
Alexandria Cassio Cortes but one of the
things that we saw is if people pay
their fair share if corporations and the
ultra wealthy for example as Warren
Buffett likes to say if he paid as much
as his secretary paid 15% if he paid a
fifteen percent tax rate a Warren
Buffett pays millions and millions and
millions of dollars in taxes his
secretary pays presumably I don't know
tens of thousands of dollars in taxes if
that but also she said you know that
we've got to get him to pay fifteen
percent now she actually messes up the
Democrat talking point on this the
Democrat talking point is that the
zillionaires are only paying fifteen
percent they should pay more they should
pay 30 percent so she doesn't even get
the talking point right but if the
talking point is also totally wrong
Warren Buffett's effective tax rate is
around 31 percent his Secretary's
effective tax rate is around 21 percent
and when you're talking about 31 percent
of the millions and millions of dollars
Warren Buffett makes every year that's a
lot more money than the 21 percent of
the who knows how hundred thousand
dollars that his secretary makes or less
who knows how much she makes so that
that just isn't true part of the reason
that they get away with this talking
point is they ignore that for first of
all Warren Buffett makes most of his
money on capital gains right capital
gains an investment income but that
money's already been taxed at the
corporate level that or the money has
been texting in many places before you
get to that number so that is simply not
true
she goes on though let's let's bring on
some more untruths from Miss OH Cassio
Cortes if corporations pay
we if we reverse the the tax bill but
when raised our corporate tax rate to
28% which is not even as high as it was
before right if we if we do those two
things and also close some of those
loopholes that's two trillion dollars
right there that's two trillion dollars
in ten years and it's one of the wide
estimates is that it's going to take
three to four trillion dollars to
transition us to a hundred percent
renewable energy economy so we got two
trillion dollars from folks paying their
fair share which they were not paying
before the Trump tax bill right they
weren't no like they weren't paying that
before the Trump tax bill if we get
people to pay their fair share that's
two trillion in ten years now if we
implement a carbon tax on top of that so
that we can transition and and
financially incentivize people away from
fossil fuels if we implement a carbon
tax that's an additional amount of the
large amount of revenue that we can have
and then the last key which is extremely
extremely important is reprioritization
just last year we gave the military a
seven hundred billion dollar attack a
budget increase which they didn't even
ask for they're like we don't want
another fighter jet like don't give us
another nuclear bomb
they didn't even ask for it and we gave
it to them so none of that is true no no
no what she just said is true but also
why do they put her on TV they can't
blame this one on Allie Stuckey they try
to blame this thing they say the
conservative made her look stupid she's
on The Daily Show she's on the left-wing
program with Trevor Noah and she goes
and she says things that aren't true
she says them in a way that is not very
flattering and she has those crazy eyes
this does not help her
my advice having been in politics for a
little bit at least is Miss Ocasio
cortes you should lock yourself in a
closet until Election Day the election
is yours and you're only hurting
yourself
but then my selfish advices keep going
on the shows come on my show come on my
show any time we'll talk it would be
great I'd love to have you out there you
should become the mascot of the Democrat
Party none of it's true none of what you
just said is true so she said that there
was a seven hundred billion dollar
increase in the Pentagon budget last
year that isn't true seven hundred
billion dollars is the total size of the
Pentagon budget there was an increase it
was about 61 billion
last year so the entire the entire
budget with that increase is 700 billion
dollars that's just sixteen point nine
percent of the federal budget that's not
a lot of the federal budget when you
figure that the government's first duty
is to protect us sixteen or seventeen
percent isn't a whole lot the entire
federal budget is four point one five
trillion dollars also the Pentagon did
ask for that budget increase James
Madison aleihi said America can afford
survival
we need more money tens of billions of
dollars more money also notice in that
clip when she's talking about the way
she's gonna pay for these programs of
hers she gets so excited she they say
how you're gonna pay for what she goes
ah well we can institute this tax oh and
then we can institute that tax oh we've
got some more taxes that we taxes yes we
can swim around and all the taxes the
trouble is the money doesn't work the
numbers don't work for her this should
not be surprising because she's every
time she goes on TV she seems to say
something that isn't true but she's
certainly it she makes it very clear in
this particular instance as she says
when when Trevor Noah asks or how are
you gonna pay for this she says well if
we raise this tax and that tax and this
tax we can raise two trillion dollars in
revenue over ten years
this is important because when people
hear trillion billion ten years that
people lose sight of the scales of money
that we're talking about the orders of
magnitude difference that we're talking
about and miss Ocasio cortez appears not
to be so Swift in math either two
trillion dollars in ten years is two
hundred billion dollars a year one of
her proposals is medicare for all we're
socialized medicine socialist health
care everybody is going to be covered by
a Medicare like program the Mercatus
Center at George Mason University
estimates the cost of this would be
three a thirty two point six trillion
dollars over the course of ten years
that is three point two three point
three trillion dollars per year the
amount of money that ocasion Cortes says
that she can raise by all of these taxes
and these are her rosy estimates is two
hundred billion dollars that is more
than an order of magnitude off where are
you going to pay for the other ninety
three percent or the 90 plus percent
that you need to pay for she doesn't
have an answer for that to put this in
perspective by the way if
medicare-for-all will cost according to
this study from George Mason three point
three trillion dollars per year last
year the entire tax receipts paid by
American citizens to the federal
government was three point three
trillion dollars it was that same amount
you would have to double the taxes on
Americans double them not increased by
five percent not increased by twenty
percent
double the taxes paid to the federal
government to pay for Medicare for all
that doesn't seem like a great case
doesn't seem like an easy argument for
Democrats to make doesn't sound like a
winning argument so what are they doing
there they're duh they're trying to
ignore the reality we know now that we
have four point one GDP four point one
percent GDP growth in the last quarter
the Obama economists told us this was
impossible this isn't going to happen it
happened joblessness is at record lows
black unemployment in particular is at
record lows which means that the
Democrats can't even race hustle going
into the election crime is down hate
crime is down I don't use that phrase a
lot because all crime is hate crime but
even that even racially motivated or
whatever all of that is down there's a
religious liberty task force that is
being instituted by the Department of
Justice this is true they're trying to
spin this as a racial thing but the
trouble is that black people and
Hispanic people and mixed-race Americans
are more likely to be religious than
white Americans so you can't even spin
that and the president Trump's approval
rating has just ticked up to 47% it's
ticked up higher than it was previously
at 45% the way the Democrats are gonna
try to win this election is by doubling
down rehashing history spinning false
narratives and getting into the politics
of personal destruction we're already
seeing it happen and we'll get a little
bit to that later I mean they're they're
going to great lengths to do this
they're trying to rename the City of
Austin so get to that in a little bit
before we do that I want to thank on a
very courageous man courageous for a
number of reasons but one because he's
one of the few Democrats who's actually
agreed to come on my show Jamie kill
Steen Jamie thanks for being here man
are you
I appreciate it you were one of the few
it's you and Tom Arnold basically and
Tom Arnold is sort of in a class of his
own you know
my resume now Domino's picture next to
me yes yeah I'm sort of like John Arnold
yeah thank you for being here so yeah no
thanks Jamie you are you're a lefty yeah
you're not a conservative no you're
you're decided and you were we purposely
kept me out of here for the headlines
just so we can actually do the interview
and I was like hey I have a list of yeah
but you you weren't just a
run-of-the-mill lefty you wrote for The
Huffington Post you were you were a woke
comedian who's variable play clubs and
all that yeah and that has changed
recently yeah that's that about I mean I
mean part of it is like even when I came
here so when I came here this is the
first like I've done Brogan's show who
has had people from both sides of the
aisle on yeah but this is definitely the
first like conservative show I write a
bit old on and even yeah and even I was
gonna say even when I said conservative
I had to put it in quotes cuz I'm so not
used to saying that word and hey
everyone here's been lovely
and really nice and I don't know what I
expected especially like being in Los
Angeles like not secretly
yeah the walls I thought and would just
be like in a dumpster and everyone was
our old set okay good the Nazi dumpster
yeah I saw it on my way over here in a
back alley in a back alley where other
people are getting to leave wow that's
right and I and everyone here has been
nice very nice and you're shocked by
this I'm sure I was shocked by when we
were talking before the show and you
were like I yeah man I really like nor
McDonald and I was like you people like
comedy you guys laugh yeah and I heard I
thought you just laughed at like like
Mexican children in cages and I Ord
Anita soon when he was on Rogen I think
no no he was on um Theo von show and he
was like yeah I really like a comedian
Mitch Hedberg and I was like what like
my mind was blown and ever since I kind
of stepped away from being political
what I've tried to do is just be like
how do I be a better person and I
started listening to not even political
voices really but I started listening to
like Tim Ferriss is show
or Rogen's more or jackal will neck and
I realized that back in the day and I'm
not I didn't hang out with like moderate
liberals like it was very left of left
of Lenin the woke bro it was like yeah
like if you told someone you were
depressed they were like that's a
microaggression towards me and you're
like cool I don't know what to do
anymore
I was depression a microaggression I
don't know no man because it makes me
sad right now and I just want to live in
like my like bubble and yeah it's very
it's a very much a bubble I mean you cuz
you're joking about this you say I'm
shocked that you guys were nice we're
half joking about that yeah yeah I'm not
really I was like this is a real thing
this bubble is how because I think
conservatives are shocked by this really
just because conservatives usually don't
have the opportunity to be in a bubble
in so much as the culture is kind of a
left-wing culture so when you're in so
you kind of hear the left-wing point of
view especially you know I lived in New
York LA and I mean these are pretty
left-wing places yeah I mean I always
disagree to that because like right now
it's like well the government is being
run by conservatives right and and but
but you're right when it comes to
narratives when it comes to loud voices
especially on social media that's kind
of like our turf and if I were to you
know listening to all these shows like
becoming friends did you you know and
and hearing other people's points of
views especially like here's what I
learned from jock oh nothing about the
military just about how like disciplines
good and I thought sort of like
discipline was like some like evil
right-wing word and it's like no that's
really good like there's a life better
yeah responsibility like taking
responsibility or like the words like
honor or family it's weird that even
those those words which should be very
positive things have been sort of turned
into conservative talking points right
and so when I started listening to these
people who were kind of demonized by my
tribe I was like well they say a lot of
stuff I really like and I agree with
like Jordan Peterson is a really great
example like when I first heard him I
literally thought I was gonna be
listening to like Nazi propaganda and he
was like saves that for his private
first press yeah
that's for the patreon subscribers yeah
you gotta pay yeah but he was like walk
with your shoulders back and have
confidence and we clean up your room and
I'm like man so many young men I needed
to hear that stuff like there are a lot
of young men who need to hear that and
even me right now saying young man well
I shouldn't be talking about young men
because they were also like Mexican
transgender people that I should be
talking about and I I think that we
should be talking about like all people
and how to be better towards all people
and me and you disagree on how to do it
but what I'm starting to learn by
talking to more conservatives or
libertarians is we still want people to
be happy and healthy and safe and if we
don't talk about why we disagree on the
policy we're never gonna actually get to
solutions you know what I mean how
widespread is it do you think on the
left that they legitimately think
right-wingers are Nazis hateful or i
think it i think it's i think it's very
cuz I did Japan so what what changed I
mean what what burst this bubble for you
and you said I'm breaking my SJW Twitter
addiction and I mean they started to
hate me I mean a lot of things I'll do
it I was in it for I was in it for a
long time I said there's some Rogen's
but one of the one of my sort of like
tipping points was my old show which was
very very progressive we had this kid
right in who not kid a man right in who
was like I I went to doctor and I was
essentially gonna die he told me I was
gonna die and I have children and I have
to do something with my health what was
wrong with him it's incredibly
overweight overweight overweight on how
unhealthy yeah and and so I I do jujitsu
I teach you Jitsu and mixed martial arts
and so I I got his personal email I
found him a gym and I think was like
Baltimore and I wrote him out like this
whole like diet thing or like here's
what you should stop eating you know
fast food said all that stuff and you
know heard back from him maybe like
eight months ten months later right
the show and is literally like my life
has changed my doctor was like shocked
I'm gonna be okay if I keep this up I
entered my first like white belt
jiu-jitsu toward him in like my kids are
so proud of me and I'm like in tears
ready let's do this you know I do i do
Krav Maga
yeah or jiu-jitsu as I call it similar a
different emphasis you know so he does
this because of you totally changes his
life totally changes his life and you
know I I had a really hard childhood in
a struggle like making a name for myself
in comedy and and all this stuff a lot
of it cuz I was very political and I'm
like choking back tears because I'm like
man all the garbage I went through is
worth it like this is what I want to do
we can read bad news every day from the
news or read Twitter or talk about who
were mad at but like this was one of the
first times I felt like I actually did
something and wasn't just shouting into
an echo chamber right yeah
so the next day we got like 10 emails
saying that by reading his email
we were fat shaming them and I have
never been more livid in my life because
we weren't like so everyone who doesn't
do jujitsu is a fatty and doesn't
deserve health care we were like here is
a very inspirational story about
something very specific that this one
individual life decided to do and now
he's not gonna die
and what I hate about a guy I guess is
the first time I publicly said victim
cultures that would you guys call it um
what I hate about it is it's like you
would rather other people die than take
personal responsibility now what I
always say with that shaming is like no
you should never make someone feel bad
for how they look there are some bigger
people who are actually healthier that
like I have horrible friends who like
like all my like hot friends who have
weird hot person metabolism who could
just eat garbage and like now I have a
bagel and I like put on five pounds
there are people who can be unhealthy
and all those premises I gave all those
premises all those liberal preferences
every wasn't enough you're given a
preference I was like man when you would
rather somebody and that's the problem
is well it's exhausting it is exhausting
to keep up with whatever the obsession
to sure is and I find
the minute because you know on the rare
occasion when I used to work in
Hollywood yeah keep my mouth shut about
politics yeah you'd have to be very
careful you're always walking on
eggshells what is the new obsession what
is this it's so liberating to say look
I'm having a conversation in good faith
I am NOT gonna be careful and choose my
words to the enth degree I'm just gonna
look I'm in good faith you are in good
faith but it seems to me the left on
Twitter especially but in that social
media angry mindset everything is so
personal yes struck t'v and angry well
and because you you're not looking at
people face to face and you're not
looking at them in the eyes and you're
not meeting their family and you're not
I mean I remember my grandparents had
pictures of them with George Bush with
Pat Robertson and when I was like Jamie
where did you go wrong Idaho thankfully
good stuff I know I know at my angst
iasts
III went to stay with them because they
were gonna put me up because of course I
was like living out of my car I was a
liberal stereotype to have a nice a this
is loud and there's like gorgeous house
outside of Seattle which is like
sellouts
but I walked in and I was ready to like
throw down with them more my Curia and
they were lovely because there were
grandparents and I so disagree with them
and I so disagree with you on a lot of
things but the more tribe alized we get
and like dude I had a blast talking to
you before the show like I have another
much fun talking to someone in like a
while and it was a very charming person
very but then when when and I also
realized by the way when I started just
hanging out with like jujitsu guys and
instead of just liberal progressives I'm
like oh this is actually the first time
I've been around minorities in a really
long time for as much as we talk about
like being like whoa can being like
intersectional or whatever but all of my
friends in college who were like the
College Democrats the woke activists it
was all like it was all white kids of
hedge fund managers and all they're all
they're you know paying full tuition
yeah you know guys you're yelling at me
about racial diversity I don't see a
whole lot of racial diversity going
right and they're like hold on I have to
go back to my
grandparents house and get more food it
was me but I what I realized was that
talking to people I disagree with I
still can get along with them
and when you look at for your audience
when you look at like when you're having
a real conversation with like one of
your liberal friends and you're not just
saying if you voted for Trump unfriend
me on Facebook or when I'm having a
conversation with you or with
libertarians or people who don't vote or
whatever you realize that like and this
sounds super like like stoner I just saw
fish this weekend but I was I stand by
it which is you realize that like we all
are hopefully trying to be better people
we all want to take care of our families
we all want to pet the dog we see you
know you know what I thought though I
think ideology is an excuse not to be a
better person I think they use it I see
it all the time and this began again
because I'm not like a real kumbaya it's
all it's everybody's problem man I see
this largely on the left not exclusively
largely because in the 1960s the left
said the personal is the political the
private is the political I was that big
feminist essay 1970 1969 and so every
aspect of life became this political
moment and the thing I try to do in my
own life because there there is an
ideological version of conservatism
which I try to eschew I try not to do it
because when you're in that fight I know
this working on campaigns you're in that
fight you just want the lower taxes or
whatever why you just why I'm gonna once
we lower taxes then everything's gonna
be great and you'll do it and you're in
the fight and then you lower the taxes
and then what and then what you know if
you're on the Left you say this we've
got to pass this new speech code and
once we do that but life is of course
much more than those things it's much
more than politics and once you do it
you got to look at yourself in the
mirror and say what what am I now well
now how was the thing where I was the
most depressed I mean dude there were
times where my mom would call me and I'm
like I can't take this phone call
I'm tweeting about feminism and it's
like she's a woman pick up the phone
she would need your help she's the woman
who makes you
actual lady right now and I'm like yeah
but she I don't get famous people
retweeting me that's right yeah I'm I
talked to my mom today like I need to
talk about the ISM I can't talk about
the people where I gonna do the is me
and like yeah talking about my mom is
like a very lame virtue signaling and
but I I once I kind of stop talking
about politics and like look we do have
I really strongly believe that we do
have institutional problems in this
country but I also believe that we can
we some we will use that as an excuse to
yet not take care of ourselves and
because again personal responsibility is
a very Republican word right and so I
love it I love that we got that well
it's weird
I think that you wouldn't be able to get
something like that's weird you know
we're the party of good yeah yeah it's a
Republican by where discipline you got
bad we got yeah and the problem is when
I stopped when I got off Twitter and
maybe it has let's do a politics in more
rigid social media I mean cuz I do think
that social media was important because
a bunch of people who felt marginalized
whether it be trans people whether be
people of color they found a voice and
they found a community right because
they they were you know you you barely
saw transgender activists like on the
news even on like very liberal on MSNBC
just Chaz Bono basically every race in
and and so so they had a voice and that
was something you have a voice after
being marginalized for so long that
you're gonna run with it and the problem
is when so for me and I can just be for
me and I am a very white straight male I
was very depressed when I lived in New
York and I didn't have I was in a rough
relationship and I didn't really like
get along with my friends and I was
struggling with comedy and so I would
wake up every day and I would open
Twitter and I would be like who are we
mad at and I would see who's trending
and it'd be like okay so it's this like
conservative writer or it's this
moderate Democrat writer who's not being
left enough cool I don't have time to
read the articles because I slept till
11 cuz I'm depressed and so sure I'm
gonna be pissed off yeah so I read the
headline
and you read the headline you read lines
about me I look awful you read the
articles and you go oh I don't get it
and I read the headline and I'm like all
right I gotta formulate a joke off the
headline because like time's tickin and
we're gonna move on to the next person
so then you come up with a line and you
act this person you don't even know I
mean jeez sure I saw have a screenshot
of like Josh Marshall from Talking
Points Memo writing fu freedom fighter
to me because I was harassing him while
he was at the beach with his kids and
I'm like haha and who won neither of us
he should've been in the ocean with his
kids
I should have been outside instead of
like angrily on Twitter not talking to
my wife not talking to my family
ignoring my poor mom yeah and what
happens is you do that to feel like a
good person because you're like I am
righteously shouting into the ether but
in reality even when I wrote something
that I believed in if I tweet it black
lives matter I believe that I think
matter is a very low bar they're not
saying what Conda forever they're saying
like treat us like people right see I'm
more on the Wakanda forever trend are
use a lot of nationalists i winner and
but i would tweet it and then I would
just refresh it to see who liked it and
see how many new falses be this is the
that's where the addiction comes in and
I was doing that instead of learning how
to be a better person instead of
volunteering my time with like an actual
charities but if you something instead
of doing comedy instead of making people
happy instead of teaching more people
jiu-jitsu would save this kid's life but
I don't want to fat shame them by like
scootch in jiu-jitsu and so well you got
to teach the lefties how to laugh though
if you do that would be another thing
that would change their lives
hey this brings me to my is then I'll
let you go I've taken a lot of your time
yeah yeah are are you ever gonna work in
this town again
I mean because you're it's not like
you're a conservative you know anything
like a left-wing guy what I forgot about
comedy is that the majority of comedy is
a lot of it is and this is what this is
what I missed which is a lot of comedy
is and what I love comics is they are so
open and they're so honest about their
screw-ups their their messed-up thoughts
and their vulnerabilities yeah and my
old crew didn't screw culture
my Oprah pretty Harvard culture my old
group of friends weren't like that
because we were so busy shouting at
other people that a lot of us wouldn't
me I can see me wouldn't talk about our
own flaws or examine our own flaws and
what I loved about spending this year
hanging out with athletes his athletes
are constantly trying to improve and
they are using discipline and they're
reading biographies about like great
leaders and like the men aren't afraid
to say that like yeah being a man is
good and that doesn't mean that you have
to be oppressing that means that like
you want to like take care of like your
family and like you want to like be
strong and like be brave and like and
that's not a bad thing and those are
qualities that women can have two etc
etc etc I'm so used to have any of a
million practices before you you don't
need the preface this is why this is a
safe space right okay a safe space no
good don't trigger me I'm so afraid to
have a kid because I think his first
words or literally he's gonna be I'm
sorry but I honestly think that like if
you just if you spend your life figuring
out how you can be a good person and if
you take care of yourself first which I
always thought was selfish you are gonna
be in a much better place to take care
of other people and to help other people
and I think people need to think about
how much time are you spending on
Twitter attacking people instead of
making stuff instead of helping people
instead of having like looking like the
person ring up your groceries in the eye
and yes Ted of just being like I'm
tweeting about the minimum wage it's
like well cool you're ignoring the
person who's in front of you right now
be king of nor McDonald's he had it one
of the greatest observations I've ever
seen on Twitter yeah he said I'm
paraphrasing I've now realized that
Twitter is an excellent place to tell
people that you don't like them very
much that's the purpose yeah that's it
and now you're outside of it in the real
world and hopefully you'll continue to
work they won't blacklist you where can
people find you yes so if they do
blacklist me everybody you can support
my show I have a podcast where I talk
about a lot of this stuff it's far
filthier I found out last minute I
couldn't curse so who saw me doing this
yeah that's okay we forgot to tell Tom
Arnold ed and then we had to bleep the
entire Jaime kill scene podcast it's
free
and Stitch around iTunes and then I'm at
Jamie Holstein on Twitter alright that's
it that's where you go and tweet mean
things to Jamie don't you jerk
so happy now on Twitter I didn't give my
Instagram because people aren't mean on
Instagram because it's just cats and
inspirational quote I'm gonna do dairy
areas prove that conservatives are good
my Instagram which is my special place
is Jamie holstein podcast go to that go
to that safe special place now Jamie
thanks for being cracker all right we
got a sec about a Facebook and YouTube
if you're on Facebook and you to go to
daily wire and give us your money
because we need your money to keep the
lights on and co FFA in my cup also
because Jamie is known for stealing mugs
off of television sets so I know he's
gonna take the leftist here's tumblr you
can get you're gonna need this I mean
these days you're really gonna need it
you've got Ocasio cortes going on The
Daily Show you've got collusion not
being a crime you've got Paul Manafort
going to jail for I don't know for
jaywalking in 1971 there are a lot of
things that are upsetting the left these
days go make sure you get this because
otherwise you'll drown in the leftist
tears and by the way you'll you'll need
this because I'm headed to DC I'm going
to the Yap conference in two days I'll
be there on Wednesday so bring it down
there we're gonna flood the whole the
whole District of Columbia go to daily
we're DICOM we'll be right back
all right I'm running late as usual this
is like the story of my life I could
have kept Jamie on for another two hours
I mean that guy's great to talk to talk
about that like walkaway moment or
they're kind of realizing this this dark
culture of SJW mean tweeting it's really
how liberating it is to be done with
that so one aspect of this talking
talking about delving into the past the
politics of personal destruction the
Democrats have no nothing to run on in
2018 in the midterm elections they've
got nothing they don't have the personal
crime stuff about Trump that's fallen
flat can't run in the economy can't run
on Foreign Affairs Isis has been
destroyed militarily
North Korea is denuclearizing we've got
satellite images corroborating that they
can't run against trade we're iron and
our trade deals the IMF is crediting
trump with boosting the global economy
they've got nothing to run on and they
can't even run on racial division which
they usually try to run on because hate
crimes are down black unemployment is
down a joblessness is down it's all
going so well so what do they do they
dig into the past ironically their own
past because the Democrats are the party
of slavery and the Republican Party was
founded to stop the Democrats from
owning slaves that's why it was founded
in 1854 and so they're delving into the
past and they're saying you know in the
old days in the olden days there was
slavery there was racial division there
was segregation never mind that were the
ones who did it and so we're gonna have
to rename monuments and rip down
monuments and rename streets and now
they want to rename an entire city of
Austin Texas I kid you not and the story
behind this is insane so they need the
censor they need to erase history what
they did is so stephen f austin Stephen
Austin is the founder of Texas the
father of Texas you know an important
figure to Austin is named after they're
very angry because he opposed an attempt
by Mexico to outlaw slavery in that
territory and he he had this comment he
said that freeing all the slaves
immediately would turn them into
vagabonds a nuisance and a menace tough
words and so there they're now saying
we've
renamed Austin and we cannot have this
legacy of this slaver but the thing with
austin is he wasn't a lifetime slave
owner he intermittently owned slaves he
also believed that slavery was morally
wrong he also believed that slavery was
contrary to the American founding ideals
that it was anti-american and he
predicted that slavery would cause
destruction and ruin for the United
States in the long run he predicted all
of those things his position wasn't very
different than Thomas Jefferson or other
other founding fathers by the way he's
right we're seeing that play out now
obviously it caused a lot of destruction
during the Civil War 600,000 Americans
dying but in this long run it's caused
this destruction because it's is such an
easy target for cynical Democrats who
have nothing to run on so they say
remember slavery that was bad let's
rename the whole town it's insane
this this proposal to rename the City of
Austin comes from the city of Austin's
equity office and they say we've got a
topple the monuments we've got to rename
seven streets because the streets have
names like plantation Road one of them
was named Barton Springs this area
Barton Springs and that was after
William Barton who owned slaves so you
got to rename that you got to rename
everything and this never ends this goes
all the way back and it never ends it
there are two points on this one the
City of Austin equity office and now you
see this especially at universities the
office of inclusion and diversity and
renaming things the office of this the
office of that of tolerance and
tolerance and whatever these guys exist
their whole job is to cause trouble to
reopen historical scabs to try to
rewrite history to try to erase history
to try to create division that's their
whole job so we can't really blame them
when they do that that's their whole
point that's why they exist what we
should do though is perhaps get rid of
those jobs they don't they don't do a
lot of great work you know the the fact
that a Yale University became a hotbed
of racial division and anti historical
activism Yale University the best
history department in the entire country
has become this place of erasing history
it that is because those protests were
egged on by the deputy assistant deputy
Dean of diversity and inclusion and
creating political trouble you've got to
get rid of those things because it just
it's just
contrived it's total nonsense and it
erases history there is no end to this
if you're going to erase the name Austin
because a guy who fervently believed
that slavery was immoral and
anti-american also didn't want to
abolish slavery immediately if you're
gonna erase him you're going to erase
everybody you're you are gonna erase
Washington you're gonna have to rename
Washington DC I don't know I bet Amerigo
Vespucci wasn't a great guy
what about did he ever like say mean
thing to his wife probably have to
rename America won't we that this to
judge the historical past because they
were not perfect people is an incredible
thing one because you're not perfect we
are not perfect none of us is perfect in
the course of justice and none of us
would see salvation to quote Porsha to
[ __ ] and the Merchant of Venice it's
an impossible standard it's just gonna
involve you totally eradicating your
tradition and see what happens then see
what happens then when you're just
guided by your ideology because
ideologies have taken hold and what and
destroyed tradition a number of times in
modern history the French Revolution the
Russian Revolution Nazi Germany
communist China on and on see what
happens does that lead to human
flourishing does that lead to human
misery obviously human misery before we
go light I would like to direct your
attention to to a New York magazine
article on this same topic they have
this magazine order I can't show the
pictures because then they'll get me for
copyright but it says the photographer
who documents the former sites of
Confederate monuments and you can go and
look and it's just bases with nothing
there and you just see the absence of it
and it's really spooky because even if
you don't like Jefferson Davis even if
you don't like Robert Lee you just see
this absence this void and you think
gosh we're getting rid of our history
and what's gonna fill that void what
ideology is gonna fill that void is it
really gonna make things better I also
want to point out on this day in history
we're talking about medicare-for-all how
we're gonna spend 75 zillion dollars on
new social programs and that'll be great
well that'll fix everything right
mankind is perfectible that usually
works well nope wrong on this day in
history in 1965 LBJ signed Medicare into
law so that this created a major major
permanent entitlement it's given us a
lot of trouble ever since it was signed
at the
Truman library and this is because in
1945 President Truman became one of the
first Americans to propose a national
health insurance provision Truman
actually became the first beneficiary of
Medicare he signed up and he said ok I'm
the first the first Medicare enrollee
originally Medicare was for Americans 65
and older just a few years later seven
years later in 1972 that was expanded to
include some Americans under the age of
65 then in 2003 under a Republican
president and nominally a sensible
conservative president that was expanded
even further to include certain
prescription drugs Medicare Part D this
was the conservative running on
expanding that entitlement this is
funded entirely by the federal
government it's paid for in part by
payroll taxes but just in part it's and
it's been this very unwieldy thing it's
been a huge strain on the federal budget
ever since it was passed just to put
this in perspective in 2010 the Office
of Management and Budget said that out
of the 528 billion dollars that was
allocated to Medicare a huge amount of
money almost 50 billion of that was
fraud that is a program that is so Riven
with fraud because Medicaid for get they
took the the Democrats complain about
national defense the defense budget is
so big Medicare is a lot bigger than
that Medicare is and a big driver of our
debt and deficits but when you're when
you look at that program almost ten
percent of that is fraud that is a huge
waste when you're talking about this
huge chunk of the federal budget and
then a huge chunk of that is waste fraud
and abuse in 2017 Medicare accounted for
15% of the total budget that's expected
to rise to 18% over the next ten years
so it's not like it's shrinking it's
getting even bigger it's running away
and it's it's to quote mitch Daniels the
new Red Menace this time consisting of
Inc part of what that should show you
though is that entitlement programs once
they're enacted are virtually impossible
to repeal right now the Republicans
control the White House the conquer the
House of Representatives the Senate the
conservatives have the the court broadly
speaking we have so many state houses
but they can't repeal Obamacare we can
gut it we can get rid of the individual
mandate we can work around the edges but
they still haven't succeeded in
repealing Obamacare why because even
with all
that momentum it isn't virtually
impossible to repeal entitlements once
they're passed and what an entitlement
program is is a diminution of your
freedom it takes away your freedom the
bigger the entitlement the less freedom
you have because it means the more of
your property the government gets to
take the more of your liberty it gets to
demand and the bigger the government
gets the smaller the citizen gets if the
government that can give you everything
you want is able to take away everything
that you have the government's going to
give you all that health care you have
to rely on the government for health
care well guess what happens when your
baby gets sick and you say I want to
take it elsewhere for treatment either
there's nowhere else to go or the
government can say no as we saw in the
United Kingdom happened twice in just
the last year last couple of years once
that entitlement program is enacted that
Liberty is gone and so when you've got
people like Alexandria Ocasio Cortes and
lefties and socialists open socialists
saying we want to enact National Health
Service we want to that freedom will be
lost permanently there will not be
repealing it it will not come back and
those are the stakes in the election
because it's looking good for
Republicans but right now 42 candidates
are running on the left with the
official endorsement of the Democratic
socialists of America they want to do
that they want they know how important
it is they know that once they take away
your freedom there you're not getting it
back you got to fight that tooth and
nail and even wackos even clowns like
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez who doesn't
know anything who just take you lights
like a crazy person on trevor know is
show that they are peddling a really
pernicious ideology they're trying to
take away your freedom
you got to rebut them every chance you
get ok that's our show I will see you
tomorrow and then I'm flying over to DC
so if you're in the DC area maybe I'll
see you around there you can catch me at
you know any cigar bar or the Trump
Hotel you know you'll probably see me
there and because we'll be talking a yaf
at ya a young America's Foundation and
there's gonna be a really good speech
we're gonna be talking about owning the
lives and I can't wait to I can't wait
to offer my robust defense of that in
the meantime
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Dahl show I'll see you tomorrow
the michael noland is produced by seniya
Villarreal executive producer Jeremy
board senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jessa alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you
you